I want to talk about the initial
conversations that Kathy Larry JJ and
you had not about story but about
feeling about imagery and about where
those images were gonna get you to
feeling in other words did you start
your writing process not focusing on
characters but what that story would
mean to audience in terms of emotion I
think it is about feeling you know
feeling trying to recapture feeling that
the New Hope gave to people you know a
new hope maybe and they were so
delightful so lating you know so
stirring and surprising and funny and
and you know just the I think if people
walked out with their head spinning in
1977 and we were trying to think that
that's what happened to us how could we
make that happen for people today is it
possible and you know I said you can
never be the original again but what you
can do is you can try to get at those
feelings try to create images of excited
people in their way and work variations
on them because at times have changed
the technology has changed and we have
new generation of actors in the movie
everything is different and everything's
the same and and we wanted to get that
feeling or like oh people could be happy
walking in here at the heart of Star
Wars and you can describe it in all
sorts of different ways but it's all the
same thing I think it's it's humor its
humanity its vitality it's the force and
it's this idea of a vital power and to
me as even as a 10 years old when I
first saw Star Wars the the spectacle
and the adventure and the the romance
all that stuff was undeniable the music
the sound effects that George Lucas did
the impossible he did everything right
and but for me the number one thing on
that list was the humor and it was that
amazing
humor that that made you want to be with
those people and and so when we started
talking about it from the very beginning
before I even met with with Larry when
Kathy and I first talked that idea of of
trying to make this thing feel authentic
and and making it funny were two of the
things we talked about the very
beginning and the authenticity part was
partly about going on locations and
building sets and having as much
practical stuff but the humor element
for me is that thing I thought oh my god
to be able to get that feeling again
it's what you were talking about would
would be the the dream if we could and
how did you in Harrison have
conversations about that about that
character and about what was funny to
Hawn and what was funny to Harrison you
never spoke to me I had I had the best
time I think an impossibly great time
and and the reason I had a great time is
because there was no burden on me there
was the leadership of this thing was so
strong so clear the intentions were so
so clear to me that it left me as an
actor with nothing to do but show up say
the words we you could grunt and shrug
and and I would have got what you what
you what you wanted but I felt
wonderfully comfortable and directed and
I mean that in the in the best possible
way I say the intention was clear from
the script but every day was a ball to
go to work and love doesn't happen every
time I also just need to say that one of
the amazing things
watching these new young actors who have
never in the case of Daisy Ridley been
in a film or John boyega who had really
only done a couple of little things I
say a little comparatively because of
this movie was so ridiculously huge to
work on but your generosity to them
and and helping them building them up
and doing every off-camera thing as much
as you I mean it was what was my
favorite thing about it wasn't just that
the movie was benefiting which it was
but I was watching these young actors
see what it's like to be gracious and
that was one of those things you just
know they're gonna carry that on and it
was invaluable we were going to school
on Star Wars we knew that we needed to
immerse ourselves in a world that George
had created but as JJ was saying Larry
was saying at the same time we were
moving it ahead into the future but we
had to understand the basic premise look
feel whatever it was that would start to
make us all find that intuitive sense of
recognizing what was in fact Star Wars
and what wasn't
and it's funny because we get asked this
all the time well how did you know and
it is this feeling that you develop
after a while when you start to get a
real deeper understanding of where Ralph
McQuarrie and some of the early
designers came up with the with the look
of Star Wars which I have to say every
time we would go back to Ralph
McQuarrie's artwork it was just
incredible what he what he created one
of the conversation and it was just a
conversation about what would actually
frighten you if the dark side would stir
reemerge and that was before we thought
about awakening but just the idea that
it would come back and it was actually
Dennis Muren
who thought well what if you could take
the light out of the sky
that's darkness and it was one of those
things that it was a vision without an
image and then as we've tried to make
that into something that we could work
with Jay Jay said and then we could turn
that into a weapon so each at each step
it would become more or or the idea of a
Nuremberg esque rally that's not really
just a rally it it leads to something
that's really serious and so the funny
thing is that the movies pretty serious
very on after I started working on it I
had this image in my head of like a
knight in shining armor but inspired by
a stormtrooper and we had been working
pretty-pretty long days just just trying
to solve the the costume of kylo Ren and
I just thought maybe there was something
in it like like he was the Lord of the
stormtroopers and I didn't want to make
a silver stormtrooper but an armor that
that looked resembled a stormtrooper and
we had this amazing concept artist named
Dermot Power who I asked I taught my the
thoughts that were my head the images
and he did this amazing illustration
very powerful JJ loved it but he he
immediately said this is this is not
kylo Ren this is is not something that
solves the problems and you know I love
the drawing but it doesn't work shortly
after that Kathy came into our design
room and saw this image hanging on the
wall and said you know that's amazing
what is that
I think after Kathy's reaction JJ
created the part of phasma but then he
in his brilliance cast Wendelin Christi
which which I thought was such an
amazing idea and I think the difference
between Star Wars then and now when that
happened there was no thought in my mind
to kind of change the design for a woman
I mean this was the character this was
the design this was something that we
all loved and you know Gwendolyn Ward
beautifully and I don't think that would
have happened in in the 70s the idea
that the early movies represented this
very tangible reality that you could
some you know you could visit these
places they went to Tunisia you know
they weren't inventing planets in a
weird way everything seemed relatively
familiar to you so that was the sort of
the underlying foundation for us that we
just wanted to take that I did that one
step further and and how do you how do
you do that well you might say well you
would use miniatures or whatever you
know to do
that kind of thing well the truth is
that the technology available to us
today is just so ridiculously advanced
that you you know you kind of do the
polar opposite you you you try and build
up this sort of technology to a place
where you can actually render a desert
or create a forest or build an ice
planet and then literally that frees you
up to then just concentrate on you know
trying to get the best shots into the
movie and and part of that again is is
you know there is in the very business
that I work in this idea that sometimes
more is more and more is better and the
truth is you know sometimes you know
they had to show a degree of restraint
in 1977 and 1982 you know that's part of
the landscape but what we wanted to do
is show that restraint again and and
make sure that the audience felt focused
on what they were really watching and
the in the notion that they wasn't just
being overwhelmed by the surroundings or
the planet or what was going on and of
course you know you want it to be
exciting and you want it to have all of
that but the feeling of that you're
immersed in this movie and these events
were really happening people were
running to the Millennium Falcon and it
was going to take off and I thought if
we could you know obviously that was the
goal was just trying to do that and
trying to make that happen and make you
really believe that those things were
happening what types of one thing that
they've when I saw the The Star Wars for
the first time it was so mind-blowing
because it just did look real and for
some reason one of the just struck me so
hard was that the the sandcrawler
you know and not knowing how the hell
they did it like what was real what
wasn't because those giant treads were
right there and you just couldn't tell
and it seemed like up till that point
any one of us could go
that's a miniature that's a matte
painting I know you know and somehow
Star Wars just blew all that away just
wipe the table clean said we're starting
over and we're not gonna let you have
see the seams we're not gonna let you
understand give you a hint of how it was
done and what was cool about this we had
at our fingertips sort of every
available resource but the question was
well what would they have done and how
can we approach this not just grab the
most obvious thing
you know do creatures that are are being
built and made build more sets where
possible but what Roger and his team
have done on this and I think better
than I've ever seen is the same thing
that I was just talking about which is I
don't think you know where things ended
what was real what wasn't I mean when
that giant creature that john boyega's
drinking water out of the trough next to
that was there those were five guys in a
big suit in 130 degree heat in Abu Dhabi
and in order with five ended with three
yeah the creature started to collapse
what's class and and they pan out their
legs but then there are other pieces
where you know when you see the Castle
battle we had a fairly enormous set
there but it was on the back lot at
Pinewood and there was no water there
there was you know it was a piece of the
set and Roger and his team didn't just
do all the the aerial stuff but also
extended the set in a way you know in
the Maz Kanata sequence when you first
meet Maas you know every creature in
that room was practical every single one
except for Maas and it was that kind of
thing where you just you don't quite
know where things are real where things
aren't and it was exactly that feeling
that that we all had we saw the the
first movie and it's a and I think the
other the other word that I kept on
coming back to his charm you know and
that's I think as human beings you
instantly relate to you know that notion
if you vote you know if you have
children you grab their soft toy or
whatever and you wobbling around and put
on a funny voice there's this sort of
inherent charm to all of these things
and you can tell stories in a very very
simple way by doing that kind of stuff
and obviously we weren't quite doing
that but we were doing the very
expensive advanced version of that and
you know you you want to have that charm
and sometimes I think the digital world
sort of relaxed some of that and it you
know it when we when we worked with Mars
and you know uncle and all the other
characters we did for the movie you want
that kind of quality and part of that
was working so closely with Neil and I
would say for example bb-8 you know I
can't tell you sometimes which shots are
digital and which shots aren't you know
because the fact that we built the
character
and if you define bb-8 and the fun of
that was that he was acted by the
puppeteers most of the time and that
means that the actors actually
understand his personality and often
what happens in the in the visual
effects world is you know everyone's
pretending there's a character there but
the character hasn't truly been defined
by something or somebody or whatever the
process is and we did everything we
could where Mars was involved that we
had the actor there saying her lines
when we did
bb-8 he even if we couldn't actually do
the action with the character he would
be acted out by the puppeteers so it's
just this incredible sort of sense of
embodying these characters with real
feeling and with real personality Frank
Oz saw the movie who's Yoda obviously
saw the movie at the premiere and he
came running over and and grabbed me and
he was so excited because Neal Scanlan
who we had literally brought out a
retirement to do this movie he was
retiring at a fairly young age because
he assumed that this kind of craft and
technology just wasn't going to be
needed anymore that everybody was moving
toward CG characters and the art of
puppeteering and what they had done what
the Henson's have done and and certainly
what had gone on in Star Wars was no
longer needed and I think that was one
of the things that we were really struck
by is that when we brought Neal into
this process and then all the people who
came out of the woodwork who are just
exceptional at what they do and they
came into this with such pride and
enthusiasm and they just did incredible
work every single day we would go into
the to the Creature Shop and just be
astounded by the work that was going on
so in a sense I think what was really
exciting to all of us is that we
rejuvenated this whole side of the
industry that thought they were obsolete
which was really exciting